Long suffering.
One of the things that I was noticing
from the stories of Jacob and a lot of
these biblical narratives is you do have
this all powerful God who is able to
kind of essentially be the hidden
protagonist in the narrative.
But then the funny thing is that he's
kind of revealing some of his qualities
throughout the course of the story.
So you were talking about,
um,
the weird paradox of the fact that God,
somehow ally was Jacob Israel to win the
fight and he does that with Abraham to,
yeah.
So my question is relating to pan seps
thing about the rats that you told like
three or four times and the number of
occasions I saw when I got my recent
videos,
you talked about it where the bigger rat
lets the smaller rat win because then
the other,
the smaller rep won't engage in the game.
So the question is,
is two fold for me.
One is God allowing humanity
to win periodically.
So that's to allow us to actually engage
in the dialogue through these stories
and to,
is it a much more primitive
version of the virtue of humility?
Which you wouldn't normally
characterize of an of an omnipotent,
omnipotent day at [inaudible].
Well,
those are excellent questions.
I really liked the second
one in particular that
that that God's decision to
allow human victory from time to time
is actually a manifestation of something
approximating humility or at least mercy.
But humility is an interesting take on it.
Well,
it's also connected to Paul's image of
how Christ handed him hands himself over
and allows himself to be defeated
by men and therefore a conquers sin,
which is man's enemy.
It's a weird,
it's the same paradox where God enters
into that dynamic with people and loses
and willingly loses.
Yeah.
Well that's okay.
So if the first thing I would say is that,
that's a really interesting analogy.
I,
I can't,
it's complicated enough
questions so that I can't go be,
I don't think I can go beyond the question
actually because it's so complicated
that I don't think I can formulate
it any better than you already did.
Like it's an interesting string of ideas.
I'd have to play with it a while to see
it does shed interesting light on why
God is amenable to negotiation
in the Old Testament,
which is really a strange,
as you pointed out,
it's really a strange thing.
It's like this is omnipotent God who
obviously can do whatever he wants and yet
he allowed,
he can be bargained with.
And then that also opens up the question
of why like your hypothesis as well.
If you don't let the little
rat win now and then,
then they get dejected and quit playing.
And that's,
I mean that's,
that's a pretty good observation if
people don't get to win now and then,
you know,
they,
that's kind of what happens to cane.
God says,
well you're not playing a straight game.
That's why you're not winning.
But
I dunno,
there's an intimation in the old testament
and I think it's more developed in
the New Testament,
maybe not that the
straighter the game you play,
the more likely you are to win.
And so maybe part of the reason that God
lets Abraham bargain and even Jacob is
because they've started to
play very straight games.
And so maybe you do when you're wrestling
with God if you play a straight game.
I mean I think that's,
I actually think that's,
I think the reason that's true is because
that's actually why we would define it
as a street gate now.
Then we could speak psychologically.
Again,
I think that what we've come to recognize
as a straight game is the game that in
the broadest number of situations across
the widest range of time spans is most
likely to produce a positive outcome.
And that's,
that's actually the grounds for our sense
of ethics that it's really practical.
Not to Belabor it too
much because there was,
there was an interesting insight from
Chesterton's demand who was Thursday where
God sets himself up as the benevolent
antagonist so as to accelerate the game.
Yeah.
Well I think that that's
a really interesting idea.
I mean there is,
there is hints I would say throughout
the biblical stories that the reason that
God tolerates Satan,
let's say,
is because without an adversary,
you're soft.
And that's,
I mean,
that's tied in with the notion that
life is something like a moral struggle.
You know,
that that's the fundamental
essence of being a moral struggle.
Now I think that that's phenomenologically
a reasonable observation.
Maybe it's maybe other people
don't experience it that way,
but it seems to me like within my
own experience that that's accurate.
Now,
I don't know what,
again,
I don't know what that says about
the fundamental nature of reality,
but I had a vision at one point that
I was in a ring with Satan actually,
uh,
believe it or not.
And um,
it was like a Roman coliseum.
And you know,
I was rather upset to find myself there,
but I won.
And I asked God afterwards
why he would do such a thing.
And his answer was he knew I could win.
That's interesting.
You know,
because like,
I don't know what to make of that.
Believe me,
I have no idea what to make of that.
But the idea was that if you're trying
to encourage someone rather than protect
them,
because those are really different things,
right?
To protect someone isn't
to make them strong,
to encourage them is to make them strong.
Then you set them a series of challenges,
right?
Right.
At the point where they may win and maybe
you could make a case that that's what
you do if you really care for someone.
Now I know that that's it.
I'm not saying that that
interpretation is correct.
I'm not,
but,
but there's something,
I mean you definitely with your children,
you know when you're wrestling with them,
say when you're playing with them,
you use,
okay.
Push them to the limit of their ability
because otherwise they don't transcend
their current abilities.
So
Yep.
[inaudible]
so we'll see some of you,
perhaps most of you in December and I
think we'll finish off genesis at that
point.
And then in the new year,
probably not till the spring,
I'll start with exodus,
which I'm really looking forward to
because I really liked the exodus story.
It's an amazing story
and unbelievably deep,
not well the ones we've covered so far,
you know,
pretty good as well.
But so thank you all for coming and
will perhaps see you in about it.